Over the span of this course,
we covered a number of steps to
building a great analytic data set.
First, we discussed the different
structures of data out there.
Then, we talked about
the various sources of data.
Then, we reviewed data field formats.
And why it's important for
fields to be in the optimal format for
their data type.
Second, we reviewed a number of
data issues that we come across,
like dirty data,
missing data, and outliers.
Then, we covered how to deal with them.
Third, we reviewed a number of ways for
reshaping our data, like transposing,
aggregating, and cross-tabbing.
And lastly, we looked at different
ways of blending our data together
through unioning, joining,
fuzzy matching, and spatial matching.
You are now prepared with a great
set of skills to build out robust,
analytic dataset.
Congratulations, at this point,
you're ready to move on to the project.